I have a problem with the way that
Oxford advertises itself to students
because while the University and the
colleges and the departments have saw
the best websites of any educational
institution about a scene it's all facts
there's no feeling behind it you don't
ever get the feeling of what it's like
to be a student at Oxford it's a very
top-down approach this institution which
kind of preaches to you gives you all
this information what I want to try and
do is a bottom-up approach so rather
than an institution preaching to you and
giving you all these facts and figures I
want to show you the view from the
ground boots on the ground view of being
a student so from one student to an
applicant what it's like to be a student
at Oxford and the way I want to dig well
we want to try and do that is making a
vlog every week with what I've been
doing in my work what are we doing
outside of my work how I've been
socializing the kind of events that are
going on in Oxford just to give you the
experience to give you the feeling
rather than the fact I figured is
nothing else that is an interesting
experiment just to see if this will take
off as a form of access
so what I've been doing this week is not
very much
this is freshers week in Oxford so um
Sunday all the freshers come up move
into their rooms and a lot of second
years and third years and in my case for
theatres come back help people with
moving in help them settle in and make
the most of being in Oxford but not
having to do lots and lots of work
already so I'm a fourth year student
which means that I'm technically part of
the JCR junior common room for
undergraduates but also the MCR middle :
room for graduate students because
technically I am a graduate student I
haven't graduated yet it's a bit weird
so freshers week for me is a bit strange
because I'm invited to all the MCR
events but I go to all the JCR events
and in a way I'm almost expected to go
to some of the JCR events and to be
honest I do myself as being much more
part of the junior corner in the middle
column just because that's what my
friends are so I've been mostly going to
JCR event so the kind of thing that
they've been doing is they have a big
marquee in little college one of the
quads and there's a bar Bothell bar in
there where we've been doing some
drinking games some Gangnam style
dancing though the club lights
Sun lights though I really should point
out there's no pressure whatsoever to go
to them when I was in my freshers week
in first year I went I think one club
night I'm just not a clubbing type
person I thought I'd give it a go this
time round so there was a phone party
yet Junction never been to a phone party
before and it was an experience I'll say
that I was right in front of a cannon
source just being like blasted with foam
but part of that it's apart from the
organised events for the JCR a lot of
what goes on this week is just kind of
reacquainting yourself with Oxford so
you're not doing work yet but you have
the time so so you have the time to
wander around the city to you know
reacquaint yourself with all the places
that you missed out on if the Sun
doesn't set I have been doing any work
this year
I am for Thea physicist and I get to
choose two major options for what I want
to do as effectively for my master's
year so I'm choosing to do theoretical
physics and atmospheric Oceanic and
planetary physics which are two kind of
opposite ends of the spectrum because
the full list of options is God
astrophysics
atmospheric Oceanic and Planetary
biological physics condensed matter
physics quantum information processing
in lasers particle physics and
theoretical physics
so theoretical physics is the most
mathematical whereas atmospheric physics
is I'll give you the closest thing to
something like geography so it's not as
maths heaviness more than a physical
understanding required and I'm like both
of those aspects admittedly I'm much
better the physical and standing stuff
because I wasn't doing physics i viddied
geography so the theoretical option is
something that I'm almost doing as a
test to myself to make myself get better
at maths because I want to apply to do a
DPhil PhD in atmospheric physics but I
want to do the more mathematical side of
things I'm interested in global climate
processes which was what I did in my
work over the summer so I've been doing
preliminary reading for both of those
courses and cracking on with the
vacation work so there's a there's a
problem set for each of them what's as
problems there for one there's a few
questions for the theoretical option
which i've been doing i've also been
preparing for my conference talk because
on sunday i am going to germany to
present the paper that I wrote over the
summer with my supervisor Scott Osprey
about the face synchronization of the
quasi vinyl and a semi animal
oscillation and again that's in the
video I made but I'm off to Germany to
present this paper at an international
conference which is just phenomenal I
really wasn't expecting to have the
opportunity to do that but it's a
fantastic boost of the CV you know
revealing to do this work over the
summer was a privilege but being able to
present a paper but publish a paper
about it and present my paper a
conference it's just such an incredible
boost to my academic cv I'm really
really lucky to be able to do it see ya
this works been quite different from
most other weeks and I've had every
other week in the
apart from the the week after you
finished your exams so in future weeks
what I'm gonna be talking about is the
kind the amount of work that I've been
doing without going into too much than
itty-bitty detail some of the content
I'm going to be doing but also stuff
outside of it so this term I'm taking a
lot stuff outside of my subjects so I'm
doing a meditation course that the
mindfulness Center here in Oxford we
have got a guy called professor Marc
Williams who's like a world leader in
the field of mindfulness meditation so I
thought good opportunity take a take him
up on it I'm also now on the committee
for the university physics society and
that's something I am you talking about
a lot in the future probably but we have
a talk to next week about nuclear fusion
which I will report back on and the
social actually physics and socials
don't only go together but sometimes we
need sign to have a center bring but
also the big thing that I'm going to be
doing this term is the College YouTube
channel as I have probably mentioned in
the past I may be each hotel my college
and it was the first student made
college YouTube channel in Oxford and we
focused previously on aspects of the
college like accommodation sport music
that kind of thing what is this time
we're going to be doing it a
half-a-dozen subject specific videos so
there's five or six minute videos about
history say and the kind of stuff that
they're looking for in applicants the
nature of the course meeting with the
tutors getting them to describe their
work and talking to students about their
experiences of the course so that's
going to be a big part of my term in
addition to the really quite
considerable amount of work I'm going to
be doing basically I want this to useful
to people I'm not just doing this as
like a self-indulgent thing I want to
help anybody who's applying give even
they have to give them the idea what
it's like to be here so if you have a
question that you'd like me to answer or
if you have something you'd like me to
cover in a video I really really like to
hear from you so you know leave a
comment on this video give me a message
and I'll do my best to incorporate that
what I'll probably do is not on to
comment on the video in the comment
section I've already revised a comment
in the subsequent video so yeah you'll
be hearing from me in a week's time
when I come back from Germany and I have
started the course proper and we've had
our first physics society event and
terms got going anyway I hope this is
going to be useful and I will see you
next week